il manifeste pour le droit ne pas
vacciner leurs enfants
et pendant ce temps les cas de rougeole
se multiplient aux etats unis
387 depuis le début de l'année dans 15
états 28 au canada mais aussi 560 en
france une flambée due en partie à la
désinformation autour des vaccins
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé on a les outils pour éviter la
rougeole le niveau de désinformation le
monde dans lequel nous vivons menace nos
succès en santé exemple dans la
communauté somalienne du minnesota le
taux de vaccination contre la rougeole
les oreillons et la rubéole est passé de
92 % en 2004 à 40 2% en 2014
le mouvement antivaccin a pris de
l'ampleur à la fin des années 90 quand
un article
finalement renier prétend faire un lien
entre vaccins et autisme mais ces
dernières années la caisse de résonance
des réseaux sociaux redonne de l'écho
aux anti vaccins et ses matches et c'est
nouveau et ça crée une asymétrie ceux
qui publient de l'information vérifiée
sont discrets alors que les apôtres de
la désinformation publie des tonnes de
choses sur internet
alors il y a ceux qui défient l'autorité
parentale
comme cet adolescent venu au congrès
expliqué la toxicité du discours anti
vaccins mes parents sont un peu stupide
dieu seul sait comment je suis encore en
vie et si dans cette famille le dialogue
n'est pas rompu
les rapports entre pro et anti vaccins
sont souvent violent pour avoir publié
un article scientifique sur le sujet
sept médecins de nouvelle écosse reçoit
des menaces
c'était très détaillé sur la façon dont
on allait me tuer explique-t-elle ces
fanatiques ne sont pas ouverts à la
discussion
ils me veulent juste morte ça ne serait
pas arrivé il ya dix ans une autre
médecin en ontario a elle aussi reçu des
menaces de mort ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal